[Música]
[Aplausos]
eu sempre quis participar num táxi eu já
participei da organização do 11 quando
foi aqui em viseu eu nunca pensei que
fosse apresentado num telex a uma vez
participação como ignorar paulo é uma
coisa assim
foi bom foi obrigado no treinamento eu
tenho uma folha e espero que não se
importa em não é habitual nos telex
stojkovic até agora não é muito habitual
ter uma folha é mais um comando não é
que eu tenho uma folha por que por que
eu fui escrevendo desde que soube que
participará neste mês desde que aceitei
o convite muito obrigado por este ato o
convite foi criando algumas idéias que
vão surgindo e sempre me sugeriu a isso
ea banda folha que foi a coisa do mês e
fui sempre apontando que o que estava a
falar e preços ele ter essa foi uma
farinhada já passou por muitos dias e
muitas têm que ver com essa lei era
horrível que eu tenho nada a fazer
a primeira idéia que eu escrevi nesta
folha a5 sobre o tema e sou craque é uma
frase e eu estava a pensar com ela terá
nesta partida entre são os que são isto
e tem apresentação começa agora ou a o
meu nome é joão paiva e vem do futuro
sempre gostei de participar num telex e
também sempre que dizer isto vai no
futuro é não vai revelar ao sol que quem
não sabe é que muito perto de viseu é
é é um local local metal e e eu como
disseram na minha apresentação eu desde
cedo tive vontade de mudar o mundo
estava vendo a minha maneira não estava
a ver coisas que eu criamos a não sabia
como também fazendo como era o mundo
então de cinema
vou tentar descobrir isso também não sei
como é que descobri que mudar o mundo é
e acho que nós aquela coisa que ajuda
muito a fundart próprio todas essas
essas frases e então eu fui deixando o
tempo passar fui aprendendo fui fiz
todos os passos da escola até que surja
uma oportunidade z fazer um gap e quando
acabei o 12º ano e nessa altura a
primeira coisa que passou pela cabeça
foi olha giro vou viajar vou fazer umas
coisas giras e depois consegue perceber
o que eu podia fazer
durante o gp que poderia fazer é que eu
realmente quero fazer que era
voluntariado integrado nessa nessa
viagem fez um projeto mais um colega meu
e foi financiado por uma fundação e teve
três que já tinham criado o primeiro foi
na guatemala durante seis semanas uma
escola primária ensinar jovens dos 4 aos
9 anos é que supostamente ia dar aulas
de educação física
uma pessoa que como eu não costumo fazer
muito curto não poder correr bem mas não
é assim muito difícil conseguir lidar
com a situação pois tem vindo a dar
aulas de inglês e depois seguiram para
dar aulas de ciências aquilo que não
voltaria a ficar expostas em quatro
semanas acabou por ter de sair porque
depois vem um piso da escola que estava
a ser construído e e pediram ajuda na
construção e eu estava eu também não sei
na construção civil mas lá estava eu
faço é fazer mais dois projectos de
voluntariado no orfanato na bolívia e
outro no banco alimentar na argentina
méxico da guatemala foi quem mais marcou
que eu para passar para essa fase da
educação física professor ensinar inglês
e ensinar ciências mais desafiante foi o
inglês porque porque uma coisa era um
inglês básico não seria difícil ensinar
uma criança de cinco anos seis anos mas
era uma criança que não falava a mesma
língua
então eu tive que aprender a falar a
língua dela para depois do poder ensinar
outra língua podem ver onde isso pode
dar errado muitos itens acabou por
correr bem e isso marca é um é um dos
modos pré esta questão do futuro e 11
uma das frases que também recolhe quando
estava a preparar isto é a frase que
marcou a mudança faz nos ter de
continuar a aprender e a mudança está
diretamente ligada com o futuro o futuro
é a mudança não é e toda essa
aprendizagem que eu tive que fazer foi o
comum se dizer um laboratório o primeiro
lote
pra mim aí o que vem aí
esta viagem não é da seara que também no
pessoal voluntariado conseguir ver
alguma coisa e conhecer o tal mundo que
criamos a e o que vem aí
era a minha obsessão do que eu queria
fazer também era comunicado
então se de ingressar pela área da
comunicação social chinesa e estive aqui
durante três anos
gostei muito
fiz o curso e antes de acabar o curso eu
fui parar é um projeto piloto que surgiu
em 2015
o piloto que era a televisão da feira de
são mateus e combinaram quando um cara
assim deu me inscrevi me espanhol será
pior portanto vamos ver o que acontece
aqui e aí tive que mudar tudo o que
sabia
toda a gente porque é é um projeto
piloto era feito de malta jovem todos
nós estávamos a começar e na televisão
da feira ninguém sabia bem o que é que
como é que fazia aquilo que queremos
fazer e temos espaço para errar podemos
errar e fazer e fazer novo porque
realmente muito essa margem nós éramos
nós já estamos a pensar naquilo e e
aprende aprende as primeiras bases para
o que faço agora é pra televisão e
também aprendi que era mesmo aquilo que
gostava
então se ele já que estamos aqui na
altura em que o estágio vou fazer
televisão
vou tentar fazer televisão que é uma
coisa que eu gosto de fazer televisão
vocês já ouviram esta sessão é cheirar e
[Música]
decide ir para a partir da visão do
estágio acabei por aí pra tv a partir do
porto onde teve a oportunidade de
mostrar muito do que já sabia mas
aprender muita coisa de novo porque como
disso são mateus chamas lá era tudo
muito novo nós na prática sabe bem que
estamos a fazer e havia erros e os erros
não sabe dos seus hábitos
as versões rádio e então desenvolve
algumas características que não tinha e
descobertas que sabia não sabia que
tinha o que aconteceu
quero avisar o mundo diferentes hã hã é
uma televisão um time muito grande e é
que vai por conviver com uma realidade
completamente diferente como adaptar
novamente ter que me adaptar à mudança
mudança na minha vida é preso é normal
para mim não era uma coisa diferente pra
mim era o futuro por exemplo e eu
cheguei lá a assembléia de deus e ver
que eu descobri descobrir que num dia
estava acontecendo uma coisa no outro
hoje
diferentes porque porque o tempo está a
mudar vai fazer um silêncio
vocês vão ficar assustado o tempo está a
mudar
os tempos estão a mudar tudo que nós
conhecemos
daqui a dez anos provavelmente vai ser
muito diferente e prova disso estava o
luiz e não estava a contar histórias de
quando em quando começou a fazer faz
agora e eu na altura também tava lutava
para mexer com as talvez já tenha
chegado há pouco tempo
isso é uma autora e nessa altura era uma
realidade completamente diferentes do
que temos agora podemos usar eu posso
dar um exemplo o mais prático lembrei
também por ter a folha lembra um zumbi
que estava a fumar e e um do nada à
espera mas já não estou falando que eu
falava eu estou a filmar um uma caneta
que vai num dispositivo que o carrega e
eu preciso escutar falar com os colegas
meus e eu estava eu fumar um cigarro é a
melhor possível conciliar o meu mas
tomara que aquela era uma coisa que há
20 anos mas tabata carreira nunca não
acontece
outro exemplo também poder na folhinha
em estudos da criança está cada vez mais
presente
outro dia estava vendo uma série que
gosto muito e que está vendo e netflix
eo episódio chama bem das neves e do
nada é uma opção que o carro para
definir qual o futuro do do episódio e o
que você pensar né
realmente aqui 160 bairro a opção
funcionar assim vou começar a fazer isso
que eu espero que o desfecho não
interessa a muita gente que não viu
espanholas num interessa
é mas a realidade é que há uns anos via
rádio
só que antes disso é regionais
só neste momento nós temos provisões
onde nos é permitido com o comando
inflacionária o que vai acontecer a
seguir já não é gravar o episódio
saltávamos cidades já passamos a sefaz
também uma faixa também iria ninguém
diria que é impossível aconteceu
e isto para falar do futuro tecnológico
o futuro e pra não estar um pouco o
futuro é agora porque o rio e vai no
futuro pois tenho a outra parte a parte
está eternamente ligada com aquilo que
eu faço continuo jun um e como diz o
outro é outra
o futuro dos media neste momento em
algumas partes é uma incógnita
é eu deixo que me lembro na última vez
que estive aqui nem exemplo uma
apresentação que ficou na cabeça uma
frase o diogo também estou aqui por
causa disso eu deixo como e eu também
desde que me lembro que não será morta
rádio a rádio não caiu
a rádio continua as pessoas continuam a
verdade e não dá tanto tempo mas também
já há algum fiando anunciar o fim da
televisão vai acabar no rosto e
eventualmente as pessoas vão deixar 26
onde as pessoas vão deixar de ver as
coisas que vocês dão atenção cuidado
internet vai de outubro os cuidados que
viu duas venham os titulares
eu estou indo aí eu vi que é um em
outubro nos vinhos vão acabar com um não
não vai não vai acabar
a rádio não acabou e é muito simples
porque porque ele é proteger sim eu tô
tranquilo
onde está porque é que talvez não vai
acabar porque a previsão vai se adaptar
tal como a rádio receptor tal como os
jornais tiveram de se adaptar porque a
mudança faz parte
como eu disse há pouco a mudança faz nos
ter de continuar a aprender uma frase
bonita eu posso dizê lo em luta o tempo
todo é ea transformação faz parte isto
faz parte nos adaptar nos ao futuro como
a televisão vai acabar eu vou ter que
continuar a aprender coisas novas
o jogo também não vai acabar vou
esse é o meu futuro eu sair não sei como
reserva o futuro não sei que vou ficar a
fazer no futuro não sei o que vou fazer
no futuro não só isso vou continuar
trabalhando televisão sou continuar a
trabalhar antes furtos fazer vou
continuar seja não sei não faço idéia
não preocupa todo que não preocupa mas
se eu não fizer nada para me adaptar
para continuar a aprender dentro da área
estou aí é que não continua o mesmo
porque eu vou ficar desatualizado
vou ficar no flu e tu vai ver malta nova
creche e assim empatar em 1 x 1 faço
isto e faça aquilo também faço aqui um
eo fiquei na parte em que cria fazia
televisão as notícias boas peças nos
outros os direitos ea cavalera
prova disso é um caso que aconteceu
recentemente
a editoria desporto da tvi foi uma
alteração
nós temos também do mesmo grupo o site
mais futebol e houve uma junção entre os
dois
a direcção de informação decidiu que
seria uma forma de unir os recursos e
expandir as possibilidades do que
podemos fazer
então numa reunião foi anunciado olha
agora vai ter que começar também
escrever algumas coisas para o site e do
nosso conteúdo vai ter que aprender a
classificá los e colocá los no site da
tvi24 e mais sol e oea
calma que como é que aprender no dia a
seguir
estava sentado numa mesa estava a
aprender música vídeos e comércio no
site
tive que me adaptar porque nós não nos
adaptarmos às mudanças comovendo é não
ficar para trás e por isso é que eu
queria que são dois comunicação social
não só quem for à comunicação social
como wando braço quase todos aquilo que
mais direcionado para quem quisesse não
está o caso na área da coisa
vamos deixar claro quem quiser realmente
continuar a ser né
depois disto quem quiser senão isto tem
que ser o mais completo possível
vocês estão na parte da formação é é uma
das partes mais importantes senão a mais
importante das nossas vidas e vão ter
que se tornar o mais completo possível
você chegou ao local de estágio é grande
seja um pequeno quanto mais completos
vocês forem mais oportunidades vocês
terão vocês chegam ao sítio e isto não
experiência pessoal mas por casos que
conheço e bem ser um sítio querem fazer
aquilo que sabe fazer aquilo que sabe
fazer mais nada por mim acho que vocês
estejam vocês não ficam de todo o país
vão ter que se adaptar
vocês podem continuar a aprender tal
como eu estou a aprender aprender há
pouco tempo você cabelos com o site não
sabia
aprendi e 45
a última frase ela pergunta afinal não
tinha não escrevi a pergunta é um
caminho à semelhança do culto isso
perguntou há pouco o que é que vocês
querem fazer com o vosso futuro e do
jazz posta o que vocês quiserem desde
que se adaptem
desde que se preparem e desde que nunca
esqueçam que continuam sempre seja que
faz das vossas vidas foram aprender
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]